Qué diferencia a estas protestas y
disturbios de otros que se han
presentado en Francia precisamente
también en contra de la violencia
policial
bueno la diferencia es que esta vez se
trata de un muerto no un muerto que está
injustificado porque claramente vimos
que la policía tenía una versión sobre
el evento de la muerte del Pequeño naela
diciendo que estaban en una situación
delicada y en peligro lo que les
autoriza de de usar el fuego pero un
video salió de una persona anónima y en
este video claramente vimos que esta
persona no está poniendo en peligro la
policía entonces ahí surgió de nuevo
todo el tema de la relación entre una
población
desfavorable en Francia que vive con
condiciones sociales muy duras muy
difíciles en varios que tienen escasez
de servicios públicos y la relación con
la fuerza de la policía que a veces es
muy complicada con esta población joven
entonces ahí estamos nuevamente con un
contexto de violencia tal cual como lo
vimos en cinco pero quiero subrayar acá
que es un problema profundo que ya hemos
visto y que entonces no ha tenido
resolución de problemas desde veinte
años precisamente a esto quería este
tema quería abordar es el caso de nael
un reflejo de este racismo endémico en
las agencias policiales de Francia o más
allá de una discriminación estructural
en la sociedad francesa
no bueno Yo entiendo que por parte de la
extrema derecha se está tratando de
imponer un debate que en Francia hubiera
una guerra civilizacional o unos
disturbios raciales el problema es mucho
más profundo que eso es un problema que
viene del problema social del ámbito
social Hay un problema de falta de
diversidad en estos varios que revela un
sistema republicano que ha construido
estos varios sin preguntarse sin
organizar la integración social de esta
población también es un problema de
sentimiento de abandono por esta
población que acusa un desempleo que es
mucho más profundo que en el resto de la
población en Francia un problema también
de servicios públicos deficientes como
lo está subrayando de población que está
viviendo muchas veces por ayudas
sociales por esta falta de empleo en
estos en estos varios y una un problema
también de oportunidades de
ahí sí podemos decir que hay un problema
de racismo o quizás de de integración
social una persona en Francia que tiene
un nombre que sería más magreb tiene más
probabilidad de no tener empleo cuando
tiene su entrevista con el empleador ahí
sí es lo único que yo podría decir que
hay un problema de racismo pero el
problema fundamental es el problema
social y de integración social de esta
población ahora como lo decíamos
anteriormente el presidente Manuel
macrón se ha negado a declarar el estado
de emergencia y aún así la situación lo
obligó a suspender una cumbre en
Bruselas y a cancelar su viaje a
Alemania se puede interpretar esto como
un intento por negarse a admitir que ha
perdido el control de la situación
no o sea todavía no ha perdido la
situación porque hay una movilización
fuerte de las fuerzas de policía y
también de fuerzas especiales en algunos
varios de Francia Hay también una
cancelación de las actividades nocturnas
para evitar justamente o sea para
limitar los disturbios en Francia el
estado de emergencia está entre las
manos del presidente es el presidente
que puede elegir sí o no de hacer el
estado de emergencia Pero estas dudas
que ha tenido el gobierno interactivar o
no activar el estado de emergencia para
mí tiene varias razones primero sería
admitir un fracaso del gobierno en sus
políticas sociales porque vemos que el
problema sigue existiendo en Francia y
también en su gestión de la crisis en
términos de de movilización de la
policía y de zona de la policía y la
población después sería restringir
las libertades fundamentales de
movimiento a una mayoría de la población
que va a recordarse entonces la
situación de covid y yo creo que el
gobierno quiere evitar esta situación de
una población que sería restringida en
sus casas después de las ocho de la
noche no después sería dar razón a la
extrema derecha que está pidiendo el
estado de emergencia y por fin sería
también un
en términos de imagen para Francia
entero por qué Porque estamos a un año
de la organización de los Juegos
Olímpicos que hay una cuestión de imagen
que ya vemos los impactos de imagen
hacia Francia porque hay una escasez de
una reducción de reservaciones en los
hoteles en Francia hay una bajada del
turismo en Francia entonces Obviamente
que el gobierno no quiere mandar esta
señal y está buscando otras soluciones
antes de activar el estado de emergencia